[Música]
no será recordada como una bella época
tampoco como un renacimiento el 2020 es
el año loco mientras la pandemia salida
de china acaba de llegar a europa el
país de la moda empieza en enero sin
cuestionarse se saluda de beso en la
mejilla se abraza se pasa de un
continente a otro el mundo entero se
abalanza sobre el teatro chátelet para
asistir algo extraño a una última jean
paul gautier ga abandona el escenario en
su último desfile 50 años de creaciones
50 años de recuerdos en los años 90 de
repente festeja vamos y nos olvidamos
del resto fue un periodo que partió hoy
en día estamos en un mundo de contadores
es una iniciativa súper inteligente
querer dibujar para cuerpos y gente
distinta de orígenes sociales y
etnicidades diferentes también los
hombres que se ponían faldas las mujeres
potentes eso también le da tiempo
hice muchas colecciones y tal vez todo
está cambiando también hay que darle
espacio a los jóvenes olvide decir eso
pero es cierto
el mundo ha cambiado la moda también la
moda y el sistema de la moda cambiaron
un sistema que hoy más que nunca motiva
la libertad de pensar pero la moda es
ante todo pragmática dinamitar los
códigos sólo sirve si es posible imponer
unos nuevos mientras la pandemia avanza
parís se enciende a favor del feminismo
moderno predicado por dios
todos somos
[Risas]
es extraordinario formidable es un
momento importante para nosotras pero
aún hay mucho por hacer en eeuu aún no
hemos tenido una mujer presidente lo
cual es lamentable
si las mujeres le dijeran el mundo estoy
segura que reiríamos mucho más si no sé
no lo hemos intentado creo que
deberíamos ensayar
a principios de marzo a la profesión
empieza a hacerse de serias preguntas
pero algunos toman más conciencia que
otros sobre la virulencia de la pandemia
el diseñador chino dawei acaba de llegar
de beijing para presentar su colección
alta porque no se reúne con nadie elige
auto confinarse mi salud no es un
problema pero no puedo garantizar que en
el avión u otra cosa no haya habido
alguien enfermo en francia las
decisiones tomadas el martes 17 de marzo
a mediodía el confinamiento dura 55 días
la industria textil
ya no fabrica productos de lujo sino
mascarillas en el mundo entero de parís
a dakar se organiza aquí confeccionamos
nuestras mascarillas 100% algodón y
nosotros luego los distribuimos
generalmente a la gente que se encuentra
en las paradas de bus o los mercados
los vendedores toda esta gente que aún
debe salir a trabajar las almas
creativas encierran el aislamiento es
propicio para la reflexión y si
aprovechamos esta crisis sanitaria para
un reinicio
[Música]
la función de la que creo que la palabra
clave de la reinvención está en la
proximidad en la autenticidad en una
forma del final de la arrogancia de la
moda de humildad casi reconsideren sus
vidas considerando como privilegio la
esperanza el amor los valores externos
pero sobre todo la creatividad y la
creación porque en cada uno de nosotros
hay alguien que crea
ya que yao jian yu jie yang hija en este
contexto como inventar un nuevo futuro
cómo crear nuevos escenarios
las declaraciones de intención han
culminado se necesitan actos concretos
hay que comprometerse a no producir y
consumir a ultranza el reciclaje y el
sobre cic lage se vuelve en tendencia
tal como lo hace la diseñadora francesa
ma jin se hace este fenómeno ha sido
aprobado en el 35 festival internacional
de la moda de hierro
la problemática del reciclaje durante
cierto tiempo fue que era feo que dichos
objetos nadie los quería así fuesen
reciclados y protectores en especial la
gran diferencia con los accesorios que
fueron recompensados es que uno tiene
ganas de llevar los puestos y en cuanto
a los desfiles están excluidos las
consignas sanitarias obligan a comunicar
de manera distinta las marcas de lujo
siguen poniendo en escena sus eventos
pero sin público o con muy pocos
invitados en sitios ventilados pero en
la mayoría de los casos la moda se está
volviendo digital las marcas hacen
películas
para empezar es una elección en el
sentido en que no tenía ganas de pedirle
a nadie que tomara un avión que se
desplazará por 10 minutos de show creo
que los momentos que transcurrieron sin
que pudiésemos viajar en ciertos
sentidos fueron una suerte una suerte
para ponernos en pausa para poder parar
parís se adapta pero sigue siendo la
capital de la libertad de expresión y le
permite al nigeriano kennedy eyes
apostrofar a las autoridades de su país
yo soy en nigeria no se permite ser
queer es imposible por ejemplo porque no
puedo pedirle a un hombre que se
maquilla el rostro en lagos de donde
vengo tengo un motivo para mostrar mi
colección aquí en parís el motivo es un
mensaje para la gente de mi lugar de
origen es como si yo les escribiera una
carta quiero que la gente que debe en
teoría protegernos un presidente la
policía quiero que vean esto y quiero
que empiecen a pensar de una manera
nueva y diferente
en 2020 la moda se movilizó hoy en día
buscan nuevas maneras de producir de
consumir de comunicar en 2.021 ya nada
será igual tal vez